let's talk about the song
that miley's going to do with you guys
to honor the black album we're talking
about nothing else matters we know from
past conversations that james you said
you didn't even want to present this
song to the band because you thought it
was too much of a love song you were
kind of ashamed of it you were
embarrassed
to show this kind of emotion on a record
right yeah absolutely yeah it was one of
those
just very vulnerable places and you know
that was the last thing especially late
80s you know we built this reputation of
tough guy and you know we're made of
stone you can't hurt us blah blah blah
and this is one of the most vulnerable
things and obviously the tougher the
armor the bigger the heart you want to
show and what you're afraid to so i was
i was shocked when bob rock and lars
both said that is beautiful that's an
amazing song it was a life-changing
experience to be
okay playing this for them and them
accepting it miley when you are now
being asked to do this song and you know
the importance of this song to the band
who do you sing it to when i first
started covering this song
it was for glastonbury because it's
about honoring music and nothing else
matters at that moment when you're at
glastonbury any of the [ __ ] that
is said about me it's my moment to kind
of prove myself because it's just
focused on the music and when i did
glastonbury it was the first time that i
went
i didn't have any of the gags and no
gimmicks i wore pants and a shirt and it
was right before actually that the world
knew that i was getting a divorce but i
knew that i was about two weeks before
glastonbury
and
i just lost my house in the fires and
this was my first show back and so i
nothing else matters to me was about the
music because
you know this whole conversation is just
resonating with me to hear like james
say that he was afraid of something and
knowing that at that point i was afraid
of so much i was so heartbroken
and my purpose was coming from this
performance um i got sober at that time
i really pulled my [ __ ] [ __ ] together
and this song was what drove me to that
place because i knew that nothing else
mattered my my life in in regards to
love was kind of falling apart but i had
my love for music so this is my love
letter
to music that's what it means to me
oh wow that's great i can't wait for you
guys to do this together let's do this
let's celebrate the black album let's
celebrate this band let's celebrate
miley with the band
and try it
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so close no matter how far
couldn't be much more from
forever trust in who we are
no nothing else
[Music]
never open myself this way
life is lost we're living always
[Music]
every day for us
[Music]
cause i know
[Music]
no matter how far
could it be much more from the heart
trust in who we
never are for what we do
never care for what we know
[Music]
never open myself this way
life is
[Music]
[Music]
every day for us
[Music]
never care for what they
never cared for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so close no matter how far
couldn't be much more from the heart
[Music]
no nothing else
[Music]
so
[Music]
wow
wow